qué es un trifinio o un three punto
un trifinio o un tri punto es ese punto
geográfico en donde convergen las
fronteras de tres países sí
y cada trifinio lleva un nombre está así
el hito esmeralda que es el punto en
donde se encuentran argentina bolivia y
paraguay está la isla brasilera en donde
se encuentran argentina brasil y uruguay
el trifinio de las tres fronteras en
donde se encuentran brasil colombia y
perú y el nuestro el punto en donde se
encuentran argentina paraguay y brasil
lleva por nombre triple frontera
ahora yo me pregunto y les pregunto a
ustedes también es tan difícil vivir en
la triple frontera
es tan difícil ser de la triple frontera
será que realmente somos tan malos como
dicen que somos que hay tanques de
guerra por todas partes espías gente que
solamente trabaja en el comercio
informal yo sé que ustedes ya tienen la
respuesta pero yo también les quiero
decir que no permítanme decirles que no
cuando viaje a israel por primera vez yo
debo confesar que también pensé que me
iba a encontrar con tanques de guerra
por todas partes también pensé que por
ahí iba a sentir una sensación de
inseguridad pero cuando llegué a israel
y conocí la realidad y viví con la gente
todos mis pensamientos mis emociones mis
sentimientos mis percepciones cambiaron
porque una cosa son las percepciones que
es lo que vamos construyendo a partir de
las cosas que nos cuentan a partir de
las cosas que escuchamos que nos dicen
que vivimos que vimos en algún periódico
y otra cosa muy diferente es la realidad
que es la que construimos a partir de
nuestra vivencia a partir de nuestra
experiencia a partir de conversar con el
local a partir de conocer las realidades
de ese sitio
y esto obviamente nos aplica solamente a
las personas a las cosas a las
relaciones sino que esto se aplica
también a los países a las culturas a
los pueblos
y bueno y esa percepción de inseguridad
y demás también también ocurre aquí en
nuestra región en nuestra amada triple
frontera
y pensar que que venimos en raíces
compartidas por un lado de los guaraníes
que eran quienes habitaban en esta rica
zona y por otro lado bueno los españoles
y portugueses que finalmente también
comparten la misma península y como
podemos negar la riqueza de nuestro
territorio siendo qué
el año pasado llegaron aproximadamente 4
millones a 4 millones y medio
aproximadamente perdón de turistas en
nuestra región que en esta zona tenemos
tres aeropuertos internacionales en
menos de 40 kilómetros y el año pasado
conforme al informe del observatorio
turístico trinacional llegaron casi 3
millones y medio de turistas
contamos con
una de las maravillas de la ingeniería
moderna que hay este pudín nacional que
es un ejemplo de integración construido
por paraguay brasil y que puede ser que
puede ser apreciada desde su lado
paraguayo y su lado brasilero
las cataratas del iguazú una de las
siete maravillas del mundo natural y no
solamente con las cataratas de iguazú
tenemos reservas naturales de la
paraguay saltos del monday barca
aventura muchas otras reservas naturales
en esta zona sabemos que en fox
yo puedo pagar en orán y es en argentina
por pagar en reales en las tres ciudades
puedo pagar en dólares sabemos eso
compartimos el mismo idioma
y brasil que tiene el portugués yo sé
que todos los que están aquí me
entienden y cuando pasaron los
compañeros y hablaron en portugués
también todos entendíamos no es raro
escuchar cinco idiomas caminando en dos
cuadros en ciudad del este
podemos comer comida china hecha por
chinos comida japonesa hecha por
japoneses parece redundante pero eso no
es común en otros sitios
y bueno y cruzar un puente de casi 500
22 metros para algunos ya es parte de la
rutina
porque porque vienen fotos cruzan en
ciudad del este y viceversa tenemos
lugares lugares diferentes maravillosos
y bueno y nos encanta ya pueden ver ahí
aquí en fosas y más aún nosotros que
tomamos mate y tereré y bueno y
finalmente los argentinos también el
mate pero pero nos entendemos
yo llegué hoy y los chicos estaban
tomando tereré ligó este tv sima está
aquí encima está que a 90 16 luna
entonces aquí quiero llegar que más allá
de esta integración meramente cultural a
la que me refiero existe una fuerte
iniciativa por parte del sector privado
si para lograr la integración pero antes
de hablar específicamente de estas
iniciativas quisiera subrayar que en
todo proceso de integración y
específicamente en proceso de
integración de fronteras siempre van a
existir problemas siempre van a existir
necesidades y necesidades compartidas
entonces qué es lo que se vino haciendo
en todo este tiempo los ciudadanos de
tanto de fondos de ciudad del este de
puerto han trabajado en asociaciones se
han agrupado etcétera para poder de
alguna manera crear como una suerte de
canal único de comunicación para
resolver estos conflictos algunas
asociaciones han perdurado otras no unas
han logrado su cometido otras no por qué
porque aquí lo crucial es que las
fronteras las ciudades de fronteras
tienen que entender que sus problemas
tienen que ser estudiadas como parte de
un todo
mi problema tiene que ser estudiado como
parte de un todo y no de manera aislada
cuando se va del este está bien pues
también está bien cuando argentina está
pasando pero por problemas económicos
eso también nos afecta a nosotros sí
y en mi caso particular he tenido la
oportunidad de trabajar con los tres
países en asociaciones
tanto locales como tree nacionales
también así que bueno que tenemos hoy en
la triple frontera
tenemos a consejos de desarrollo
formados si entre ellos está algo de fos
aquí en foz de iguazú el code le está en
ciudad del este el co despí en puerto
iguazú y tenemos como un organismo
supranacional por llamarlo así que eso
el code tree que es el consejo
desarrollo trinacional y que son estos
consejos y cómo trabajan estos consejos
son
instituciones entes que aglutinan en su
seno a representantes del sector público
y el sector privado y que de alguna
manera actúa como un órgano consultivo y
de asesoramiento al gobierno local
regional y por qué no nacional sí y como
trabajan básicamente a través de cámaras
técnicas que son grupos de trabajo
específicos por ejemplo en ciudad del
este
contamos actualmente con siete cámaras
técnicas educación cultura salud
desarrollo económico e infraestructura
acción social y básicamente lo que hace
cada ciudad es crear tantas cámaras
técnicas cuántas necesidades haya que
cubrir sí
y que venimos haciendo con otros
consejos hemos trabajado en ocasiones
para incluso aumentar o mantener las
cotas que ustedes saben que fue un tema
que nos afectó a todos aquí el coe fue
un caso específico acompañado muy de
cerca a la remodelación de nuestro
maravilloso puente de la amistad
hemos hecho capacitaciones en materia
turística a taxistas de la región
mototaxistas a policías agentes de
tránsito y a todo aquel que tiene el
contacto con el primer turista y estas
capacitaciones han sido totalmente
gratuitas
tanta es la credibilidad que ha logrado
el consejo y los consejos que organismos
internacionales se han puesto en
contacto con nosotros universidades e
contacto con nosotros y el último
proyecto que hemos trabajado fue con el
banco interamericano que fue el programa
de formación para el desarrollo y la
integración trinacional que fue un
programa que abarcó a representantes
afectó de manera positiva a
representantes de los tres países duró
casi dos años se han hecho
investigaciones en cadenas productivas
de la región se han hecho capacitaciones
en materia de diseño e implementación de
proyectos e incluso se han financiado
proyectos gracias a este pudín nacional
parque tecnológico itaipú tan bien
entonces esto solamente un ejemplo de lo
que hemos logrado en la región
pero aquí quiero finalmente llegar con
todo esto podría hablarles de miles de
proyectos más pero la idea es que lo que
yo quisiera dejar y contarles y decirles
que es lo que yo siente lo que viví es
que la gente de la triple frontera es
gente que se mueve es gente que se
inmiscuyó gente que hace parte que
transforma si es gente que digiere la
integración como algo natural hay gente
que valora el trabajo el equipo que
valora al otro que está al otro lado del
puente y lo ve como un igual la gente de
la triple frontera es así y por qué no
decir que este es un espacio de unión un
espacio de ayuda yo te doy lo que tú no
tienes tú me das lo que yo no tengo y
juntos podemos hacer muchas cosas
y un gran ejemplo de por qué porque yo
digo que es una espacio de unión se ve
reflejado aquí se ve reflejado en los
más de 20 mil brasileros perdón que
están estudiando en paraguay recibiendo
educación calidad a bajo costo se ve
reflejado en los adelantos médicos que
le ofrece el brasil y al usufructo que
hacemos nosotros los paraguayos y
argentinos cuando necesitamos porque
nosotros no contamos de repente con
ciertas tecnologías o viceversa y no
solamente hablamos de de este
intercambio sino que también en la
triple frontera se puede resaltar el
desarrollo y el crecimiento profesional
de las personas porque por las innúmeras
oportunidades de trabajo que hay en esta
región gracias a la integración de las
cadenas productivas que tenemos y eso
que atrae atrae inversores
internacionales capital extranjeros no
pero claro
no somos perfectos
necesitamos por supuesto que necesitamos
mejorar muchísimo más aún pero mi anhelo
y yo estoy segura que el anhelo en mucha
gente aquí es que nuestra triple
frontera sirva como plataforma de
crecimiento que sirva como plataforma de
mejora en la calidad de vida de las
personas
y para mí un y la unila es un ejemplo un
hilo es un ejemplo que está recibiendo a
casi 5.000 estudiantes al año de manera
gratuita ofreciendo educación de calidad
a jóvenes de latinoamérica y así entre
ellos por supuesto muchos paraguayos que
orgullosos dicen ser de un hilo
y así como un nilda es un ejemplo de
educación integrada por qué no pensar
también en una salud integrada en un
hospital en un centro de atención que
pueda brindar salud de primer mundo a
gente de la triple frontera y por qué no
de latinoamérica
pero para ello tenemos que legitimar
nuestra integración como legitimamos
nuestra integración acompañando los
procesos de construcción de políticas
públicas asegurándonos de que las
políticas públicas de frontera sean
estudiadas como tal
foz de iguazú no tiene las necesidades
diferentes a brasilia ciudad del este
tienen necesidades diferentes asunción o
cualquier otra ciudad puerto azul lo
mismo tienen es necesidades diferentes a
buenos aires gente acompañemos el diseño
y construcción de políticas de frontera
y asegurémonos de que de que eso sea
construido como tal con las necesidades
de la región tenemos necesidades
diferentes
y por supuesto no podemos dejar de lado
el paso fronterizo y la comercialización
sabían ustedes que tan sólo el 25 por
ciento de las demoras en el tránsito de
mercaderías se debe a los malas malas
rutas y caminos esto fue un estudio
hecho por el bit mientras que el 75% de
estos retrasos se deben a justamente a
la mala gestión a procesos ineficientes
entonces por qué no pensar también y
anhelar una gestión coordinada de
fronteras que implicaría tener una
gestión coordinada de fronteras
implicaría un mejor control fiscal y
para fiscal implicaría seguridad
fronteriza y facilitación en el comercio
y en el tránsito de personas está una
frase que me gusta mucho que decía que
en la medida en que las fronteras crecen
y se integran se disminuyen los límites
políticos las instituciones pueden
buscar integrarse pero quienes
verdaderamente hacen a la integración
son las personas
hacemos integración acompañando como ya
dije la construcción de políticas de
frontera hacemos integración siendo
embajadores de nuestros países chicos
hacemos integración resaltando las
coincidencias y celebrando las
diferencias que nos unen para suena
paradójico celebrar las diferencias que
nos unen pero es así
hacemos la integración juntos
así que esta región señores necesita de
jóvenes estudiantes empresarios
ciudadanos que quieran hacer las cosas y
mi tarea hoy mi misión en esta tarde es
a invitarlos a ustedes que están allí
sentados a que construyamos a partir de
hoy y hagamos de esta región un
territorio distinto muchísimas gracias